There’s a quote that says “the beautiful
thing about learning is nobody can take it
away from you.”
But what good is learning if the knowledge
might hurt you, drive you mad, or even kill
you?
It just sits there in your mind, like a stick
of dynamite with an invisible fuse.
It could blow at any moment.
All it’d take is a careless slip of the
tongue, and you might turn into a talking
home appliance.
This is a conundrum faced by anyone dealing
with an Infohazard - a certain kind of anomaly
often dealt with by the SCP Foundation.
Before we get into some of the craziest examples
of infohazards and what they’ve done to
people, because let’s face it, that’s
what you’re really here for, first we have
to answer that big question everyone’s a
little afraid to ask: Just what is an Infohazard?
And how does it differ from a far more common
type of SCP, the dreaded Cognitohazard?
Well we’re glad you were finally brave enough
to ask.
First, cognitohazards are anomalies that are
dangerous to perceive through one of the senses.
A well known example is SCP-096, which is
actually a visual cognitohazard.
You see its face, and you’re toast.
It’s as simple as that.
And cognitohazards exist for all of the other
senses too: hearing, taste, touch, even smell.
Infohazards, on the other hand, are different.
These anomalous effects are triggered when
you start trying to express or describe something
about what you’ve perceived, and when you
do, things start to get real weird real fast.
Maybe you’re trying to explain what you
just saw to family members, friends, or the
police.
Maybe you’re a member of SCP Foundation
staff, trying to write up a report, or a new
experiment log.
Or maybe you’re a YouTube channel, trying
to create entertaining yet informative breakdowns
and explanations of anomalies from the SCP
Foundation.
If any or all of these apply to you, then
Infohazards are going to be your worst enemy.
But as we look at some of the strangest examples,
we’ll try our best to resist their effects.
First, seeing as it’s so hot out, how about
we take a relaxing dip in the pool while we
tell you all about SCP-1128.
What is SCP-1128?
Well, that’s a loaded question.
Technically speaking, it’s a massive, predatory,
aquatic creature, but despite its huge size,
the creature can hunt its prey in any body
of water.
Whether you’re stepping in a puddle, relaxing
in the bath, or say, chilling out in the pool,
SCP-1128 can track you down and potentially
eat you alive.
In one particularly horrifying test, a D-Class
was drinking from a simple glass of water,
when the aquatic predator emerged, yanked
them inside, and ate them.
Okay, so maybe you’re feeling a little nervous
now, but don’t worry, you’re still safe.
Some people have even survived their attacks
from SCP-1128.
Well, their initial attacks anyway.
The creature has a tendency to come back,
again and again, relentless in its ravenous
hunger for human flesh.
Whenever it attacks successfully, all that’s
left is some blood floating on the water.
But again, please don’t worry too much about
this creature, we don’t have another 682
on our hands.
After all, it’s an infohazard, it can only
start hunting you if you receive a written
or verbal description of the creature.
Oh, or some kind of visual representation
of the creature, too.
Actually, on second thought, you may want
to get out of the pool.
Now.
And put down that drink too.
Instead, let us tell you a nice little story.
You step into a bar, smelling of fine liquor
and rich mahogany.
You even get a whiff of some fine, leather
bound book.
You see us sitting at the bar, motiong for
you to come over, and you decide to approach.
You’re intrigued by our winning smile, and
our vast knowledge of anomalies and SCP Foundation
lore.
You take a seat next to us and order a drink.
Get something fancy, it’s on our tab after
all.
Our treat.
“What does this have to do with Infohazards?”
you ask.
“That’s the thing about SCP-1893, kid,”
we say, our dulcet tones smoother than scotch.
“You can never just talk about it.
It’s an Infohazard that forces information
about it to be delivered like a story.
That’s why we’re in this bar right now,
that’s the set up.
It expresses actual information about itself
through the dialogue, see?”
You nod, beginning to grasp the concept, as
the bartender serves you your drink.
It’s been forever since you’ve been to
a bar.
Feels good to be out again, honestly.
You drink deeply, savoring the flavor, but
you almost choke when you see the man standing
in the corner.
He’s so large and so distinctive, it surprises
you that you hadn’t noticed him before now.
He stands in the corner, a freakishly tall
and muscular guy - like a basketball player
who decided to become a pro bodybuilder.
His muscular arms are bulging out of his white
vest, and a pair of bull’s horns are tattooed
across the top of his bald head, making him
look like the devil made flesh.
He stares at you with a subdued kind of annoyance,
as if to say that you’re not in real danger
quite yet, but if he wanted, he could grab
you and twist your head off like a bottlecap.
“What’s with the huge guy?” you ask
us, more than a little concern in your voice.
“Oh, him?” we reply with a smirk.
“He comes with the anomaly.
He appears in every SCP-1893 experience to
an extent, though his level of involvement
varies.
If SCP-1893 doesn’t perceive you as an annoyance
or a threat, then you’re good to go.
But if 1893 starts to feel like you’re gonna
cause it some problems, then the guy with
the horn tattoos is gonna intervene.
Speaking of which…”
You look up, and see that the giant man is
now standing next to you, brow furrowed in
visible rage.
He picks up your drink, and crushes the glass
in his hand without flinching, dripping booze
and blood onto the counter.
He snarls, “I think you’ve had enough,
buddy.
Now it’s time for you to leave, or we’re
gonna have to get physical.
Understand?”
You don’t need to be told twice.
You grab your hat, get up, and leave the bar,
abandoning us on our lonely stool.
But our next Infohazard still awaits…
You like poetry?
Japanese poetry, yes?
The humble haiku
It’s dear Nine Three One
A unique infohazard
It’s so poetic
Though specifically
It takes the form of haiku
So, what does that mean?
A rigid structure
The first line, five syllables
Then seven, then five
We can’t talk about this
In ways other than haiku
It is challenging
Object class is safe
It is kept at Site-19
Need third tier clearance
So, what is this thing?
SCP Nine Thirty-One
It is a rice bowl
White, with a blue band,
And a crackled blue pattern
All inside the bowl
And we must confess
We took that one from the file
Man, haikus are hard
Three inches in height,
Four point five inches across.
(Metric doesn’t fit)
No makers’ marks found;
Suspected to have been made
Late Nineteen Hundreds.
Really makes you think
On the skill of these poets
Sans anomalies
Sure, it can’t kill you
But writing these drives you mad
Curse Nine-Three-One
Trapped in this rhyme scheme
Makes the Old Man’s Torture World
Look like a resort
Okay let’s move on
Other SCPs to see
We’re sick of Haiku
Okay, back to normal.
Time to shake off the structure of SCP-931,
and talk about another iconic infohazard:
SCP-3007.
This incurable infohazard is a lot less whimsical
than a rice bowl that forces you to write
and speak in haiku, in fact, it’s literally
killed several people, and some in surprisingly
gruesome ways.
The main component of the Infohazard is known
as SCP-3007-1, this is an extremely vivid
anomalous hallucination that affects those
under the 3007 umbrella, known as SCP-3007-2.
To be afflicted with SCP-3007 is a truly horrifying
and debilitating condition.
The hallucinations occur an average of four
times a day, with each episode lasting for
as long as an hour - and during these episodes,
the victims are at risk of grievous bodily
harm, or even death.
So the question now is: What exactly is the
SCP-3007-1 hallucination?
To the people experiencing it, they appear
to be transported to a strange, alien world
consisting of a huge number of white towers
or pillars, stretching into the sky.
SCP-3007-2 specimens are trapped on a series
of bridges, incredibly far off the ground,
that connect these various structures.
This anomalous area is known as SCP-3007-3.
It’s important to remember that people transported
to this world still remain, physically, in
our own.
However, any damage sustained with SCP-3007-3
will carry over into our own reality.
To give one particularly gruesome example,
some people fall from the precarious bridges
and tumble to their deaths in SCP-3007-3.
Back in our reality, they suddenly explode
from the damage of an invisible high-speed
impact, killing them instantly.
There’s much more to SCP-3007, enough that
it probably warrants its own explanation,
and the SCP Foundation takes it extremely
seriously, believing that, if the infohazard
is allowed to breach containment and become
contagious, it could result in an XK-Class
End of the World Scenario.
As a result, anyone found to be infected by
SCP-3007 is contained and summarily terminated
to reduce the risk of it spreading.
To make things even worse, there are also
concerns about SCP-3007-3 seeping into our
reality, as those standing within a two-meter
range of SCP-3007-2 during a 3007-1 episode
can actually hear the sounds from the terrifying
hallucinatory reality.
Okay, that was a little scary.
How about instead of talking about falling
to your death without falling at all, we talk
about a nice movie.
Goncharov, by Martin Scorsese, one of the
best gangster movies of all time.
What, you’ve never heard of Goncharov?
It’s got everything - action, suspense,
romance, a mountain of black thorns, on which
lives a dark tyrant of terrible and unknowable
power.
You’re sure you haven’t seen Goncharov?
Well, here’s the thing, all signs point
to movies like Goncharov and many others simply
not existing.
This comes as a result of SCP-2747, an infohazardous
phenomenon that causes people to talk about
works of fiction that don’t exist.
These works often feature commonalities, like
an ethereal or disturbing tone, ambiguity,
black thorns, and a sinister, mysterious antagonist.
The Foundation is doing all they can to hunt
down and suppress SCP-2747, but it’s proving
more difficult than they’d imagined.
Currently, the leading hypothesis is that
these tales may have actually existed once,
but were erased from reality, leaving only
the residue of memory and the odd scrap of
evidence around.
Many researchers speculate that the various
pieces that form SCP-2747 are anafabula, pieces
of fiction accidentally composed with the
perfect elements to cause them to quite literally
erase themselves over time.
Now the greatest concern that the Foundation
has about these anafabulas is that they might
actually be one, and their reality is on the
precipice of collapse.
But we really don’t have time to unpack
that right now, and like SCP-3007, a full
explanation of this anomaly would take some
time and is probably best tackled on its own.
But there you have it, folks: Infohazards.
They say that knowing is half the battle,
but in this case, it’s the whole battle,
and if you know, you lose!
Not really a battle at all come to think of
it… more of a trap.
But whether it’s a vicious mega-fish, a
strangely buff man with bull tattoos, a poetic
rice bowl, or a nightmarish ordeal of daily
hallucinations, there’s no doubt that Infohazards
are some of the most strange and fascinating
anomalies that the Foundation has to offer.
Oh, and of course, how could we forget the
most well-known Infohazard of all: SCP-2521.
This entity is so infohazardous that its Foundation
file entry is written in pictograms.
This is because, whenever information is recorded
about this entity, it manifests and steals
it.
If you write it down, it’ll take the paper.
If you make a note of it on a computer, it’ll
take the computer.
And of course, if you talk about it, it’ll-
Oh no, not again!
Ahhhh!
Phew, that was a close one, but I’m ok,
for now at least.
But don’t worry about me, go check out “SCP
XK Class End of the World Scenarios Explained”
and “ALL the Little Misters Explained”
for more collections of fascinating anomalies!